The answer is 2 plus or minus the square root of 19, all divided by 3, or we
could list this as 2 3rds plus or minus root 19 divided by 3. Either way we
write it, these two solutions are correct. We get these answers by first making
the negative of b, so this will become positive 4. Negative 4 squared is 16,
and these numbers multiplied together are positive 60. We have negative 4 times
3 times negative 5. Because two of these signs are negative, we wind up with a
positive product. This is where I mentioned a sign error usually occurs. You
want to watch out to see if you have an even number of negative signs or if you
have an odd number of negative signs. We add 16 and 60 to get the square root
of 76, and then, we simplify the square root by breaking it down to 4 times 19.
The square root of 4 equals 2, and then, we can split up 6 into 2 times 3. This
allows us to root a common factor 2 from each of the terms. We know 2 divides
into 4 two times, and 2 divides into 2 one time. This leaves us with 2 plus or
minus 1 root 19 in our numerator and positive 3 in our denominator.